hello everyone my name is Pradeep Salani
I'm an engineering manager focused on
simplifying authentication for anta's
customers my name is Richard Liu and I'm
a product manager focused on
streamlining the user experience for
authentication for add those customers
authentication is complex passwords have
progressed to keys certificates and
multi-factor off basic authentication
has shifted to advanced more secure
protocols such as Kerberos LDAP samo and
a single tenant monolithic applications
have evolved to multi tenant
containerized applications distributed
across hybrid and multi cloud
environments it's clear that
authentication has become increasingly
complex yet more than ever critical to
get right ensuring a secure and
integrated authentication experience
requires both time and expertise this
leads to onboarding friction as
enterprise's shift workloads to
containers in the cloud causing delays
and modernization plans on the other
hand security risks have far greater
implications multiple authentication
solutions for example maintaining
certificates alongside protocols such as
Oh a DC may increase the chance of
security breaches an improper access
control can lead to miss configurations
and vulnerabilities in fact in a recent
survey 78% of organization's site
security not cost as top priority when
deploying identity solutions what's the
end result administrators spend
excessive time on deploying
authentication solutions and preventing
miss configurations in their environment
the complexity is taken further with
hybrid and multi cloud environments as
enterprises modernize their applications
and adopt solutions such as anthos
they'll be faced with the fragmented
identity challenge across multiple
environments each environment is built
on a different identity store for
example Active Directory for on-prem
cloud identity for Google Cloud and iam
for AWS and Azure many of these
environments may use the same identity
provider or maintain a bespoke identity
solution for example we have some groups
in other clouds using I am accounts
users an on-prem using both Opta and
Active Directory and users in other
clouds connecting to Active Directory
mergers and acquisitions add to the
complexity in addition to employee
identity customers also need to manage
partner and user and workload identity
essentially that identity solution is a
mess so how do we enable customers to
manage their clusters across multiple
environments each with a different
identity provider and protocol during
this session we'll walk through two
separate workflows users authenticating
to the anthos control plane and
workloads running on at those clusters
accessing GCP api's and services let's
start with user authentication meet
charlie who's a platform administrator
charlie manages a cross-functional team
of developers focused on building and
maintaining ITP platforms within their
organization charlie's team maintains
two separate environments gkd on-prem
and GK on AWS
he needs to ensure his team has proper
and secure access to the kubernetes api
server to perform management and
troubleshooting tasks Charlie is faced
with highly complex identity
requirements his organization has
already started modernization efforts by
shifting on-prem workloads to containers
which upgrade around-the-clock to
support both internal and customer based
applications within this team alex is a
developer working on their internal HR
application and is provisioned with in
Active Directory on-premises Alex needs
administrative access to GK on-prem
clusters to perform management tasks
with a recent acquisition of us started
Charlie's company brought in developers
such as Blake that are maintaining
projects on AWS with identity stored in
dr. Whitby's access to a customer facing
SAS application to perform
troubleshooting on gke on AWS clusters
and there's other employees maintained
in different identity solutions that
further add to the complexity so how do
administrators such as Charlie managed
such complex identity environment let's
take a look at some options what are
some options for identity Charlie can
use kubernetes identity
starting with client certificates
however this is insecure due to the need
to maintain private keys that are
typically handled on insecure media
anyone with access to these repositories
maintain unwarranted access to the
cluster Charlie may also opt for basic
auth but that's mostly limited to test
and dev environments since credentials
never expire and passwords cannot change
without restarting the API server there
also a service account tokens which
present risks as well with users that
access secrets and can authenticate as a
service account we recommend open ID
connect or OID C for short given the
long-lived sort lift and refresh tokens
but it's not available for every
environment where is it currently
available for n throws let's start with
on Prem customers can already leverage
external IEDC identity providers such as
ad FS to authenticate to DK on Prem
clusters we currently have GA support
for OID C and alpha support for LDAP for
GK on Prem we've also recently launched
beta for OID C access to DK on AWS
clusters and are looking to add support
for dkt on GC P in the future
traditionally Google Cloud has offered a
synchronization based identity model
requiring you to synchronize identities
with Google Cloud while this may work
for certain scenarios there may be
concerns around consistency and latency
for a hybrid or multi cloud deployment
with anthos we want to meet you where
you are and enable you to use
third-party identity providers and
authentication protocols you no longer
need to synchronize identities with
Google Cloud or worried about
consistency across environments we want
to save you time and reduce friction
during the onboarding process let's take
a look at how this will work with the
demo starting with GK on pram this demo
we'll walk through three user journey
Charlie will configure a no NEC identity
provider Active Directory Federation
services also known as a DFS for his
team to authenticate to a GK on-prem
cluster outlets will authenticate using
legend cloud CLI without requiring and
cloud identity account with a G cloud
anthos Oz log in command Alex will also
authenticate from the cloud console
while this demo focuses only on GK on
Prem the user experience will be the
same for any anthos cluster including
endows on AWS before getting started
Charlie needs to perform a few steps to
enable OAC authentication though need to
reach out to his organization
administrator who manages Active
Directory domain services and provision
and additional server for ad ad FS which
enables o ADC support as you can see
Alex and Blake are provisioned as users
in the ad FS instance and members of the
same group platform developers the
administrator registers an OTC client an
ad FS with to redirect URLs one for
cloud console in one for G cloud CLI the
administrator may customize claims to
include group membership information and
tokens for use with kubernetes art back
policies the minister provides Charlie
with Oh IDC client details and Charlie
proceeds to create an and those cluster
and configure oh I see in the user
cluster configuration file on an admin
workstation let's take a look at this
file there are a few fields that are
important for OID see the issuer URL or
the URL of a DFS is used by the
kubernetes api server to discover public
keys for verifying tokens the client ID
is a client application ID used to make
authentication requests to ad FS the
client secret is used by the G cloud CLI
and cloud console to exchange
authentication codes for an ID token the
user naming group specifies claims in
the ID token to use as use for naming
groups there are a few other fields such
as scopes extra params and see a path
that can be specified based on your
configuration and identity provider
deployed cloud console proxy should be
set to true if your Open ID provider is
not reachable over the public Internet
this employs a reverse proxy in the
kubernetes cluster after creating a user
cluster with this configuration charlie
can create kubernetes rback policies
allowing the platform developer group
and Active Directory
to view pods in all namespaces you can
create a cluster role in cluster role
binding Charlie needs to create a login
configuration file containing details
about one or more clusters and provide
each file to developers who want to
authenticate you can do this using the
command GK control create login convey
and passing the cube config for the user
cluster let's try it out by default this
creates a config file called cube
control anthos config diamo let's take a
look at this file this configuration
file contains the ODC information
provided during cluster creation as well
as information about the kubernetes api
server the file can be distributed to
alex and used to log into clusters alex
and blake can access this file
distributed through a secure URL and
stored in a well known path once alex
has access to a login configuration file
alex and log into clusters to perform
cube control commands add some log in
using the g-cloud CLI or cloud console
the CLI experience starts with two
control and dos config file with several
cluster definitions containing
information about the identity provider
in OD see there are two clusters
available one of which is configured
with a DFS 4gk on-prem alex and ssa api
server using the G cloud CLI with the G
cloud and those odd command Google cloud
identity credentials are not required
and the component can be installed
simply by running G cloud components
install and updating to the latest
reflowed version the input is a cube
control anthos convey login
configuration and the output is a cube
convey which will be used by cube
control to send requests to the
coronaries api server containing ID and
refresh tokens this will create a local
cube config in the current directory
let's run to cloud anthos auth login to
login if alex is not passing the list of
clusters the command will exit imprint
the available options and request a user
to specify the cluster they want to log
into let's login to the a DFS cluster
it's the same command as before except
now we pass in a cluster argument
specifying the cluster name we'll
perform an open ID credit to exchange
starting a connection to the ID
P to allow Alex to login the IDP would
return an authorization code which we
will take and sent to the ibid P and get
an ID and refresh token these tokens are
written to a cube config file used by
cube control we have a user account
under Alex's name and we've made it part
of a group that is defined an active
directory under platform developer we've
created our backs and applied them to
our API server you can see a cube config
file has been generated so let's take a
quick look at what this cube config file
contains as you can see we have a cube
config generated with the ID and refresh
token generated for a user if we run a
command using cube control and the cube
config to get pause it will return a
list of the running pods on the cluster
so let's try that so let's take a look
at now how Alex can authenticate using
the cloud console Alex navigate to the
cluster section in cloud console and
look at a list of available clusters to
log in we previously logged into a DFS
2gk on Prem now let's try octo with AWS
so let's click on log in and see through
there's three available login options
token basic auth and authenticate using
an external identity provider so let's
try the third one this redirects us to a
octal login page where we can log in and
as you can see Alex has successfully
logged in to the cluster running on AWS
we currently support ONC authentication
with third party identity providers for
GK on Prem in AWS in the future we'll
add support for additional environments
such as JCP and other clouds as you just
saw in the demo charlie's organization
administrator uses a DFS with active
directory provisioning etfs acts to the
onboarding friction as organization
administrator may have whistles or
funding constraints or maybe because of
compliance reasons
provisioning a DFS may not be even an
option in addition there may be a hidden
cost associated with managing and midi
maintaining
and in DFS so what if anthos supports
authentication with active directory
using elder or Kerberos instead of
provisioning ETFs let's see how that
works with the demo
in this demo we will walk through how to
configure LDAP with anthro SDK on Prem
cluster LDAP support is added in anthos
1.4 dot 1 and is in alpha state it is
assumed Charlie has created an admin
workstation and admin cluster and has
reached out to the organization
administrator for LDAP configuration
charlie creates user cluster
configuration using GAE Kordell
command-line tool for our demo we have
prefilled configuration specific to our
environment which we will be using let's
take a look at the user cluster
configuration file we have named our
cluster as GK on him
LDAP all fields related to
authentication are under authentication
anchor as charlie is not using a DFS the
ODC section is kept disabled if needed
by DC and Alda can be enabled
simultaneously the LDAP section is
enabled under LDAP anchor the name
represents the human readable name of
the LDAP server the host this field is
provided by organization administrator
and is typically the IP address or the
host name for Active Directory domain
name services at alpha we only support
simple LDAP connection type support for
start TLS and alda pass would be added
in the future the base DN represents
where user entry exists in the active
directory the user attribute is the name
of the attribute which precedes the user
name in non DN only supported value at
alpha is C and which represents common
name member attribute is the name of the
attribute which records a user group
membership for Active Directory this is
typically member of attribute
after filling in all configuration
fields Charlie creates a user cluster
Jiki on Prem LDAP using GK cattle to
this step will take some time to
complete once user cluster is created
you can check if LDAP is configured
correctly by checking status of anthos
identity service
Charlie creates our back policy to allow
users and the active directory security
group platform developers new various
kubernetes resources as you can see the
group over here represents the active
directory security group platform
developers Charlie then generates an
login configuration for the cluster
using GAE cattle command line tool
Charlie then proceeds to share this
login configuration with Alex Alex
installs a G Cloud SDK and uses G cloud
Anthes auth login coupon to get cube
config for user cluster note the
argument to the login config is is the
file which was shared by charlie
since we are used we are logging into an
ad server bill select option 1 this is
the username in the elder and the
corresponding password one successful
the above comp this command will
generate and keep config for Alex to use
as Alex this member of platform
developers group Alex should be able to
view kubernetes resources let's check
that out with Kip cartel comma this
completes our demo on how L depend used
with GK on Prem clusters let's take a
look at how everything fits together on
the front-end Alex can authenticate
using CLI with G cloud and the earth
login or cloud console by navigating to
the login button of the backend we have
a service running in the cluster called
anthos identity service which is
configured as a web token Authenticator
this service enables support for
different authentication protocols such
as po IDC and under the front-end works
alongside the backend by acquiring
tokens from the identity provider
generating a gift config file with the
appropriate format for the bank head to
consume in the future we will be adding
support for additional authentication
protocols in anthos identity service we
have spent some time talking about user
authentication to anthers gk clusters
but what about workloads running on
enforce clusters communities work loads
aren't self contained they often need to
authenticate to services outside the
cluster for example charlisse teams may
have a workload that deed asks us to a
GCS bucket how can you best secure
workload as a single GCP api and
services let's take a closer look today
you can use service accompiish and store
them as secrets workload can use these
secrets to assess GCS bucket but these
secrets are difficult to
ordered and managed what if each
workload could use its built-in
kubernetes native identity that i
kubernetes service account to
authenticate to GCB workload identity
for gke enables kubernetes were closed
hosted on any cluster to authenticate to
Google Cloud in a consistent way without
the use of service comp keys this
currently works for gk on GCP and will
expand to other environments like AWS or
on-prem in the future let's see it in
action in this demo we will walk through
how to enable workload identity on
anthers cluster on GCP and use workload
identity to assess Google Cloud API
without downloading service account key
first charlie creates a nonetheless turn
on GCP with uproot identity enabled with
g-cloud command line tool not the
argument to workload pool option has to
be off format project ID followed by
suffix as we see dot ID dot group in
Charlie's case project ideas on Prem ID
be test this step would take couple of
minutes to complete
after creating a cluster with workload
identity Charlie creates Google service
account which will be used to assess GCS
pocket charlie configures I am policy to
allow service account GSA app 1 to
assess the pocket upon artifacts using
gsutil command-line tool next charlie
configures queue cuttle to assess the
anthers cluster next charlie creates
namespace for the workload called
path 1
every namespace and kubernetes has a
corresponding default kubernetes service
account associated with it
Charlie creates an iamb policy binding
to allow default service account for
namespace ACK want to use Google service
account GSA - app one
after this step
Charlie adds a notation to kubernetes
service account
Charlie non-deployed sample workload an
app one namespace to verify if workload
in f1 can assess GCS bucket in this case
the sample workload is G Club Cloud SDK
slim the Bakuman should give us an
interactive shell with Cloud SDK
installed now Charlie will use gsutil
command to view the packet contains
this demonstrators demonstrate spot uses
google service accounts when calling
Google Cloud API as you can see anthos
identity service along with workload
identity offers a seamless solution for
managing authentication to multiple and
first gk environments supporting user
and workloads and providing a seamless
onboarding experience as a result you
can get started quickly with the product
that has built in enterprise-grade
security you can save boss and
streamline your identity configuration
by leveraging existing identity
providers authentication doesn't have to
be complex or insecure simplify identity
with anthos identity today thank you